[Music]
when you look at this what do you see
to me this is one of the most beautiful
fascinating and frustrating things I've
ever seen
that's because I'm a mathematician and
these hypnotizing curly cues have
haunted people like me for 150 years
what we're looking at is a glimpse of
the Riemann hypothesis it's one of the
most important if not the most important
unsolved problems in all of mathematics
you may have heard about the Riemann
hypothesis because it's one of the
Millennium Problems of the clay
Institute what that means is that the
person who solves it not only achieves
immortality in mathematics but also wins
a one million dollar prize
but there are other reasons to care
about the Enigma that is the Riemann
hypothesis if the hypothesis is true it
would solve a mystery as old as math
itself that is the mystery of the prime
numbers
countless theorems in Fields as far
apart as cryptography and quantum
physics assume that the Riemann
hypothesis is true which means that we
have a lot riding on this single
unproven statement
so what is it what is the Riemann
hypothesis why has the search for a
proof become something of a holy grail
for mathematicians and what do these
strange curly cues have to do with all
of this
my name is Alex katarovich and I'm a
professor of mathematics I'll serve as
your guide as we explore the Riemann
hypothesis
in order to build a somewhat
sophisticated understanding of this
hypothesis what I'm going to try to do
is mention some slightly advanced
concepts now you don't need an advanced
degree in mathematics to go on this
journey with me what I'm going to do is
try to lay the groundwork step by step
in a visual and intuitive way
so to begin let's Venture into the
chaotic and Elusive Universe of prime
numbers
this is Factor city where the primes are
literally the building blocks of all
numbers
now every whole number is a building and
it's been constructed out of its Primes
the one-story houses are exactly the
Primes
now thanks to the ancient Greek Euclid
of Alexandria we know that the one-story
buildings keep going on forever if you
can walk that far
but depending on where you're standing
you might want to know how many
one-story buildings do you see around
you
this is what we want to understand about
the prime numbers and what we currently
don't
you see the prime numbers seem to just
pop up randomly among the natural
numbers all the way out to Infinity
[Music]
in the late 1700s mathematicians were
really starting to wonder whether it was
possible to predict the places where
primes would appear
now a teenage boy named Carl Friedrich
daus was especially obsessed with taming
the primes he calculated massive tables
of primes going all the way up to 3
million and looked for patterns we can
see the data that Gauss collected on the
prime numbers by using something we'll
call the prime counting function
the graph of that function will show us
exactly where the prime numbers appear
as the numbers get bigger and bigger so
the graph stays flat until you hit a
prime and at that point it jumps up by
one here's what the graph looks like out
to 10.
and out to a hundred
and now out to 3 million as far as Gauss
went at this scale those bumps we saw
early on have smoothed out leaving a
pretty Pleasant curve
when Gauss looked at this data he asked
himself is there some other function
that I know that has pretty much the
same graph
now as luck would have it at around the
same time Gauss was also playing around
with logarithm functions you might
remember that a logarithm is a function
that undoes exponentiation much in the
same way as division undoes
multiplication
what Gauss noticed was that the graph of
something called the logarithmic
integral function that's a function
whose slope is one over log X looked
suspiciously similar to the graph of the
Prime counting function
here's what they look like together you
can see why Gauss made the connection at
this scale they're so close you can't
even distinguish them
to understand what the slope of one over
log X has to do with prime numbers let's
pay another visit to factor City
what Gauss imagined was that if you're
standing at address X and you looked
left and you look right the proportion
of one-story buildings that is primes
that you would see around you is roughly
the same as one over log X
this suspicion became known as gauss's
conjecture
after Gauss formulated this conjecture
his student Bernard Riemann went on to
do something absolutely incredible with
it but to understand what Riemann did we
first have to go back in time a little
bit to meet someone else
this is Leonard Euler one of the world's
first students of calculus later on in
his life he wrote many influential
textbooks and standardized the modern
math notation that we still use to this
day if you've ever written something in
standard function notation you know like
y equals f of x well you can thank or
perhaps blame Leonard Euler
in Euler's time mathematicians were
trying to understand the general
structure of infinite series what that
means is you're trying to add up an
infinite sequence of numbers like one a
half a quarter an eighth and so on
forever sometimes that total sum is a
finite number which we then call a limit
if a Series has a limit we would say
that the series itself is convergent in
this series our limit is 2. on the other
hand if we were to add let's say One
Plus One Plus One Plus One Plus One
Forever well that sum would eventually
become larger than any finite number and
so we would say that that series is
Divergent
foreign
to tell if a given series converges or
not so for example this series which is
called the harmonic series turns out
actually diverges even though the terms
themselves are getting smaller and
smaller
this is really rather not obvious and
takes some mathematical gymnastics to
verify
now what about this series the sum of 1
over the squares of all the positive
integers it wasn't hard for
mathematicians to show that this series
does indeed converge but the question
was what is the exact limit
Euler shout to mathematical super
stardom when he solved this problem what
he realized and proved is that the limit
is pi squared over six isn't that weird
what in the world does Pi have to do
with the squares well that's another
story for another time
so full of adrenaline from his early
Victory Euler kept going he found the
limits of the sum of one over the
positive integers to the fourth power
and to the sixth power and to the eighth
power
now let's try to study all these series
at once let's write s for that exponent
when we do this we Define What's called
the zeta function
in other words Zeta of 2 is the sum of 1
over the squares
and Zeta four is the sum of one over the
fourth powers and so on
Euler proved that all of these converge
but only when s is greater than one
but here's where things got really
interesting
Euler discovered that the zeta function
could be expressed as an infinite
product one for each prime number of an
infinite series here's what you do for
each prime number you add up 1 over all
the powers of that Prime to the s
if you multiply all those series over
all the prime numbers you get the zeta
function
[Music]
Euler's Discovery hinted at an intimate
connection between the zeta function and
prime numbers but it would take another
100 years for the full meaning to reveal
itself
and that's when our friend Bernard
Riemann would make a major breakthrough
in prime number Theory and that
breakthrough would potentially allow us
for the first time to understand the
profound mysteries of prime numbers so
riman he's born in 1826 in modern day
Germany he's an absolutely spectacular
and Innovative prolific mathematician
and among other things his novel
approach to Geometry actually lays the
mathematical groundwork for Einstein's
theory of relativity Riemann was also
one of the founders of complex analysis
which is a branch of math that studies
functions with complex inputs and
outputs and he realized he might have
something new to say if he studied from
that point of view Euler's zeta function
you might remember that the square of
any real number is positive so 2 squared
is 4 but negative 2 squared is also 4.
so there is no number whose square is
negative one it turns out that it's
really rather useful for mathematicians
to have a number whose square is
negative one so what did we do we just
made one up we called it I for imaginary
so whenever you see I squared what that
means is you should replace it with
negative one this means that any real
multiple of I like 3i or 2i these are
all imaginary cousins of the real
numbers
when you take combinations of real
numbers and imaginary numbers you get
something we call a complex number
complex numbers might look like two
numbers but they're actually just one
number expressed as two parts the real
part and the imaginary the thing is
these imaginary and complex numbers they
aren't imaginary at all they're just the
natural extension of our usual number
system from one dimension to two they're
plotted in what we call the complex
plane with the real part going left to
right and the imaginary part up to down
once you have these complex numbers you
can study complex functions that is
functions with inputs and outputs living
in the complex plane
and so armed with the power of complex
analysis Riemann opened up a whole new
perspective on the world of mathematics
Riemann wondered what would happen if
you allowed the zeta function to take
complex inputs that is he allowed s to
be a complex number so let's take the
complex exponent s equals two plus three
I for example
and plug it into Zeta and the function
will look like this
now if we add each term one at a time in
the complex plane we can see how the
series begins to spiral beautifully
so Riemann had successfully accomplished
what he set out to do he extended the
zeta function to the complex plane
but just like Euler Riemann found that
the function only converged when the
real part of s was greater than one now
Riemann had a brilliant idea he realized
it was possible to extend the zeta
function to the rest of the complex
plane Riemann used a technique called
analytic continuation which allowed him
to break open the hidden potential of
the zeta function now analytic
continuation is an advanced Concept in
complex analysis but it's possible to
make sense of it intuitively you can
think of it as a logical problem-solving
method to extend the domain of a
function in order for Riemann to fill in
the missing part of the domain in
Euler's data function he had to create a
brand new function this function would
take the same values as the zeta
function where they both converge but it
had to make sense everywhere else on the
plane too
so the secret to analytic continuation
is that there are really two functions
at work at once one is the original zeta
function which has limited scope but the
other is this new function the Riemann
zeta function which extends Beyond The
Domain that Euler defined
remember this
now we can take a closer look at it and
finally begin to understand its
Mysteries you see when Riemann extended
the domain of the zeta function
something kind of amazing happened in
the new territory that Riemann uncovered
suddenly the zeta function can be seen
Crossing through the origin what that
means is for some inputs the zeta
function evaluates to zero we call these
places The Zeta zeros
some of the Zeta zeros are easy to
explain when you input a negative even
integer the zeta function equals zero
but we don't need to worry about these
so-called trivial zeros it's the
non-trivial zeros that we need to talk
about
these other Zeta zeros exhibit a very
compelling pattern and that pattern is
the central theme of the Riemann
hypothesis
all of the non-trivial zeros lie inside
a single region called the critical
Strip This is where the real part of s
is between 0 and 1. Riemann proved that
there are infinitely many zeros to be
found in this critical strip but here is
the most important takeaway from
riemann's groundbreaking 1859 paper
Riemann hypothesized that all of the
non-trivial zeros will lie not just
somewhere in the strip but on a single
vertical line smack dab in the middle we
call this the critical line which is
where the real part of s is exactly
one-half this is exactly the hypothesis
that now Bears riemann's name and the
million dollar bounty
now at this point you might be wondering
why does the location of these
non-trivial zeros matter
and what does all of this have to do
with prime numbers
I don't blame you let me show you
exactly why riemann's hypothesis is of
such profound consequence to number
Theory and let me do so by sharing
riemann's final discovery
remember gauss's Prime counting function
from the very beginning of the video
well for technical reasons we're going
to slightly modify it right now but
don't worry we'll preserve the essence
of the function instead of stepping up
by one every time we see a new prime
number which we'll call P let us Step Up
by log p and we'll also do the same when
we encounter P Squared and P cubed and P
to the fourth and so on so let me try to
explain why we're doing all of this
Riemann found a surprising connection
between this modification of gauss's
conjecture and his new zeta function he
discovered a wave that corresponds to
the zeta function at s equals 1 and
showed that gauss's conjecture would
follow if only you could show that this
wave was the fundamental frequency which
means that it more and more closely
approximates the prime counting function
as they both grow to Infinity
so here's what the prime counting
function looks like with that wave that
Riemann discovered Riemann realized that
the Zeta zeros were exactly what he
needed to adjust this straight line to
match the jagged counting function every
time he added a Zeta 0 it contributed a
harmonic
here's what the first harmonic looks
like when we add it on if ever so gently
tries to smooth out the Wiggles of the
modified Prime counting function
what happens when we plug in the second
Zeta zero little better right what about
the first 10
or the first 30 or the first 60
you get the point
Riemann was able to rigorously prove
that if you add up all the harmonics of
The Zeta zeros all infinitely many of
them you get a perfect match to gauss's
modified Prime counting function
so riemann's hypothesis showed that the
distribution of prime numbers can in
fact be predicted
the location of prime numbers is
profoundly connected to the location of
these non-trivial Zeta zeros this means
that if the Riemann hypothesis is indeed
true it would tell us everything we
could possibly have a right to know
about the distribution of prime numbers
needless to say Riemann was unable to
prove the full hypothesis in other words
neither he nor anyone since has been
able to show that every single
non-trivial Zeta 0 lies on that critical
line
at one point a massive Computing project
checked over 1 billion non-trivial Zeta
zeros every single day the computer was
looking for a single errant zero if
found just one then the Riemann
hypothesis would fall apart
[Music]
in the end of the 10 trillion zeros that
the computer checked every single one
was on the critical line
but if you see a pattern holding again
and again and again it's still
impossible for machines to check it all
the way to Infinity
so Brute Force computation will never
resolve the Riemann hypothesis
that means there's still only one way to
be sure of it and it's the same way that
the ancient Greeks did their math
rigorous absolute mathematical proof
[Music]
foreign
[Music]